see ya
deme Griff's are these magnificent elite
combat mounts will size their way
through armor and flesh with their
razor-sharp claws and beaks
Demi's are a form of monstrous cavalry
and they have this kind of dense lioness
musculature they leverage that master
thunder into combat and spread fear
amongst the enemy ranks they're also
pretty rare so only the most renowned
lies the Empire get to ride them into
battle they're also wrapped in thick
plates of ornate armor so they're hugely
resilient and great in long drawn-out
combats as they pin enemy units in place
and tear away at them we really wanted
to capture the sense of pride these
creatures radiate their part eagle part
lion so they have this real sense of
poise about them our animation team
spent a long time studying the movements
of these creatures and the results are
very convincing the way they move really
embodies that nobility in that sense of
Mike that these elegant alpha predators
display
[Applause]
subscribe to our YouTube channel and see
the Democrats in action in the first
total war war hammer in engine trailer
this Friday
you